aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter ses
oeuvres de maurice calque à un
plasticien architecte designer est aussi
urbanistes né en 1921 en pologne
c'est une sculpture en bronze vr6 les et
patiné du genre figuratif est aussi
grande bosse alors cette sculpture
représente une forme animale
rappelant l'oiseau endémiques de l'île
maurice qu'on appelle le dos l'artiste
accorde une attention particulière sur
le travail des traits des formes des
lignes sur quoi vont vraiment sa fiche
et les caractéristiques propres à cette
espèce courte sur pattes avec le bec
recourbé la tête légèrement retirer en
arrière supportant un bec volumineux et
le corps général généreusement arrondi
indique la lourdeur de l'animal
réputé pour sa maladresse dans ces
mouvements est par sa nature paraît 16
ces petits traits horizontaux à bout
arrondi qu'on retrouve de chaque côté de
100 corps dodu sont ses ailes atrophiées
cette disproportion semble présenter un
handicap pour le dodo et un grand
obstacle pour lui de son volet
proprement alors l'artiste
en créant cette heure voulez participer
à la recherche archéologique dans le
rapport permettrait de affirmé que le
dodo n'existait pas à l'île de la
réunion
alors il a fait ça qu'on lui a confié
l'aménagement du boulevard banque en
1996 où il a conçu et créé le grande
ibis qui est reconnu comme l'oiseau un
des milk de la réunion même si joie au
dodo n'a pas existé à l'île de la
réunion
sa présence est toujours cité par la
neurologie